at the start of the movie A group of
teens enter an abandoned building in the
middle of the city they appear to be
looking for someone very important just
then the building starts shaking as if
an earthquake is hit the group dashes
out of the place in horror but what they
see outside sends shivers down their
spines the city which was sprawling with
life just a few minutes ago has been
laid to complete waste by a nuclear
strike it appears as if another world
war has recently taken place and for
some reason the only building that has
been unaffected is the one the teens
were in a while ago as expected the
teens become scared and rush back into
the building they believe that they are
hallucinating and decide to sleep there
until everything is fine 36 hours pass
by and once again another earthquake
hits the building when the group
Ventures out this time they notice a
highly futuristic city which is several
hundred years more advanced than the
real one in this world currency has
become Obsolete and everything is bought
via a fingerprint scan the group is left
in utter disbelief at the strange
occurrences and they finally deduce that
the building teleport them to a
different version of Earth every 36
hours then we are taken back to a few
days ago on how it all started Ronin is
a struggling boxer while his sister
Beatrix is an aspiring University
student both of them have been out of
contact for quite some time now but
today they separately receive a voice
message from their estranged father Alex
who requests they meet him he also
mentions a certain building on 156
Prospect Street which is revealed to be
the same one from the start of the movie
although the siblings are not thrilled
to be contacted by their absent father
they still decide to meet him at Alex's
house Beatrix and Ronan run into each
other and find out that their father has
been missing they searched the whole
place but find nothing suspicious then
they go to check the garage where
beatrix's childhood friend Harry also
shows up and decides to help them in the
search soon the group finds Alex's
emergency bag which has a strange
ball-shaped device in it there is also a
newspaper article which reads that Bill
Clinton has been assassinated this is
extremely weird as the former U.S
president is still alive the only person
that ever did anything to Bill's ass was
that sweet sweet Hillary a while later
the worried siblings head to the police
station to report their father's
disappearance however after hearing them
out officer Stone mentions that he can
do little to help them as they don't
know if Alex has really gone missing or
has voluntarily disappeared in a
last-ditch effort to ask for help Ronan
talks about the building his father had
mentioned earlier but the cop once again
dismisses it claiming that it is
abandoned with no other leads the trio
decides to go to the building as they
were told it is abandoned however on the
walls they noticed strange graffiti that
describes alternate timelines and
histories for instance one writing says
on my Earth terrorists flew planes into
the Twin Towers on October 23 2001. this
puzzles them as the terrorists actually
flew into the Twin Towers on September
11 2001. another writing says avoid
Earth 33 the contagion has spread while
another still says Earth 468 is safe
locals are friendly no weapons it turns
out that there are many alternate
universes where things happen
differently I want to go to the one
where where Sonic the Hedgehog is real
suddenly the trio hears loud thudding
noises which causes the building to
shake and the lights to flicker
frightened they try to run out but find
themselves locked inside the building
after a while they eventually managed to
get out but are taken aback to discover
that the building has transported them
to an alternate Earth devastated by
nuclear blasts soon they noticed some
pedestrians and ask for help but instead
get threatened with guns just then a
roving Patrol shows up and shoots down
the pedestrians prompting Ronan and the
others to flee back into the building
Harry being a nerd theorizes that there
are many versions of Earth and somehow
the building has teleported them into a
different version this also explains the
strange graffiti they saw earlier inside
the building they meet a woman named
Paulie who claims to be a traveler
Between Worlds she confirms Harry's
doubts and explains that the building
transports anyone within it to a new
random world every 36 hours in hostile
worlds such as the one in which they
currently reside she suggests that they
stay inside the building and not
interact with the locals hearing all
this the group ultimately decides to
sleep to pass the time but after a while
they're woken up by the same armed
Patrol that murdered the pedestrians in
the next scene Ronan and the others are
taken to a nearby settlement where they
are confronted by their fearless leader
surprisingly he turns out to be the
alternate version of Officer Stone as
the two parties talk it's clear that the
armed Patrol are not aware of the
existence of alternate universes Paulie
decides to hide this information from
them and makes up a story that they are
merely confused travelers from Kansas
who are heading up North however Harry
recognizes officer Stone from their
world and thanks him for his help this
puzzle Stone as it turns out that before
this version of Earth was nuked he was a
police officer here as well hence he
concludes that the four are spies from a
rival gang and takes them hostage God
damn it Harry he then orders Tinker the
local surgeon and Gadget man to
interrogate them first Beatrix and Ronan
are selected and before their
interrogation starts Beatrix airs her
personal grievances with her elder
brother calling him out for abandoning
her after their mother's death it turns
out Ronan blames himself for their
mother's death and claims that he
distanced himself from their family
because he always ends up hurting his
loved ones soon Tinker shows up and
starts chatting with the siblings he
appears to be the only one who is aware
of the alternate universes he reveals
that this Earth was an amazing place to
live until the Islamic Republic of
Pakistan collapsed in 99 and its nukes
found their way around the world the
bombs which were the size of suitcases
were sold in the market and in no time
they got into the wrong hands and
wrecked everything Tinker further
reveals that the man who first brought
the nukes to his City came out of the
building he then shows them footage of
the nuclear terrorist attack and in a
shocking turn of events the perpetrator
is revealed to be Ronan and beatrix's
Dad Alex he is the main reason why this
version of Earth was destroyed as the
siblings watch in horror Tinker grows
increasingly angry and threatens to kill
them if they don't reveal their father's
whereabouts I think he went out for milk
they say Beatrix tries to explain that
she doesn't know where Alex is but the
gadget man refuses to listen for a split
second Tinker takes his eyes off of
Ronan allowing the former boxer to
administer a Chokehold and subdue him
then he breaks free from his bondage and
also helps Beatrix up meanwhile Tinker
wakes up desperate for revenge and sets
off his own suitcase bomb to take
everyone down with him seeing this Ronan
once again knocks him out with a solid
punch to the face then the siblings
quickly free their friends and rush back
to the building in one of their
abductors cars after a while Stone
learns about the bomb and orders Tinker
to shut it down however the gadgetman
refuses to comply and reveals his plan
to take the bomb to blow up the building
before leaving he advises his comrades
to go the other way to save themselves
elsewhere as Ronan and the others reach
halfway their getaway car runs out of
fuel forcing them to make the rest of
their Journey on foot they safely make
it into the building but so does tanker
who has arrived outside with the bomb
fortunately the building transports them
to the next World just in time to escape
the nuclear blast Harry is under the
impression that there are finally going
back home but Paulie tells him that
there is no going back home and heads
out surprisingly this world is more
technologically advanced than their
version of Earth for instance the
smartphones and laptops are all
transparent the little fancy the group
assumes that they have traveled to the
future but Paulie reminds them that it
is just a different version of Earth in
the same year to learn more about the
place they split up but unbeknownst to
them it's revealed that tanker has also
arrived in this world on their way Harry
stops to buy something and learns that
everyone pays with their fingerprint the
fingerprint scan reveals that in this
world Harry is a wealthy and corrupt
corporate lawyer seconds after they
leave the shop Tinker arrives there buys
all the gadgets he can and gets busy
working on something turns out that he
too is a wealthy guy in this world
meanwhile Harry and Beatrix sneak into
this world's Harry's apartment and hack
into his computer interestingly both
Harry's have the same computer password
Beatrix 928 it's clear that he has a
major crush on Beatrix which she was a
woman obvious about until now Beatrix
then looks up her dad online and learns
that in this world her father Alex died
three months ago in an accident at work
I.E the same building they also find out
that Beatrix went to college and Ronan
didn't exist in this world on the other
hand Ronan and Paulie explore Alex's
house which turns out to be empty he
then shows her the device he found
earlier which Paulie immediately
recognizes she reveals that it could
only be from the core World which is the
world where the building was constructed
Paulie comments that the core world must
be thousands of years ahead of the real
Earth in terms of Technology after a
while Ronan opens up about his troubled
childhood where he had a bad temper and
often got into fights he also reveals
the reason why he blames himself for his
mother's death one day while Ronan and
his mom were driving home he got into a
fight with a trucker on the highway his
mother tried to stop the fight but in
the process got run over by a speeding
vehicle after that the Carver family
fell apart a grief-stricken Alex stopped
working and Beatrix had to cancel her
College plans to take care of him after
finishing up his story Ronan leads
Paulie to his dad's car on searching it
they come across a bag that contains a
message telling Ronan to get out of the
house immediately suddenly a car pulls
up outside and the same three men from
earlier emerge ordering Alex to come out
when no one responds the men barge
inside but Ronan and Paulie swiftly take
them out after this the two get inside
the Assassin's car and flee meanwhile
Harry learns that his Doppelganger from
this world has done some very bad things
hence he gathers up some evidence and
emails it to the media exposing his
other self brutally Tinker finally
completes working on his device using
which he can seemingly control the
City's power system he then drags the
device back to the building and soon
Ronan and Paulie also show up after a
small confrontation between the two men
Tinker assumes that the caretaker of the
building is hiding nearby hence using
his invention he wants to hack into the
building and bring out the caretaker
just then Harry and Beatrix also arrive
and the latter threatens to kill Tinker
however Ronan convinces her to stand
down as he too wants to find answers
with the approval from the group Tinker
finally starts his device and this
causes the building to shake violently
for a while no one emerges but when
Tinker increases the power and threatens
to destroy the building someone comes
out from the elevator shockingly it is
none other than Alex himself he commends
Tinker on his ability to connect with
the building and then direct him to the
top floor claiming this is where all the
answers are once Tinker leaves Alex
tells his children that he and their
mother were not born in what they
perceived as their home World much to
their shock he then instructs Ronan and
Beatrix to find their mother claiming
that she is the only one who can take
them back to the core world the
ball-shaped device from earlier is the
key to finding her Alex further mentions
that the building has been running for a
long time and whatever its original
purpose was and whoever built it are
long gone in fact he is not the
caretaker of the place but a regular
passenger who wants to find answers just
like everyone else suddenly tank arrives
at the elevator screaming at Alex for
deceiving him but before he can say
anything further he is shot and killed
by the cunning old man Alex then leaves
the building despite the children
pleading with him to stay after the
building transports them once again
Ronan Beatrix and Harry venture out to
explore the new world while Paulie waits
for someone suddenly two more versions
of Paulie who had been hiding in the
building all along show up the movie
ends as the three doppelgangers play
Rock Paper Scissors to determine who
will accompany the rest of the group
into the new world subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching